okay
nothing to it
okay
thank you
is
okay
bit of that
[Music]
um
is
okay
okay
okay
thank you
okay
so
thank you thank you
thank you all dr fauci
thanks for your leadership thanks for
being here
two weeks ago uh uh
i spent some time with you and dr
francis collins
excuse me uh the director of national
institute of health and nih
he gave me a tour of the vaccine
research center in bethesda maryland
and uh it's the place where our top
scientists spend
years researching and developing
vaccines and treatments of all kinds of
for all kinds of viruses
the brilliant team there made possible
the rapid deployment and development of
covet 19 vaccines and they're truly
remarkable
and this administration will follow the
science to deliver
more breakthroughs you know uh
we are doing that to beat cop coven 19
and other diseases like cancer
which is something that so personal with
so many families including
me and kamalas and many of yours
we've asked dr eric lander renowned
harvard mit scientist to serve as my
science advisor and head of the office
of science and technology policy and
co-lead
the president's account of the
presidential council on advisory science
and technology
these are the white house offices that
bring together the country's top
scientists
to address our most pressing needs and
they'll be part of the work to develop a
darpa-like advanced research effort on
cancer and other diseases just like we
do
darpa in the defense department which
develops breakthrough projects
to secure our national uh security
and relatedly i'm delighted to see five
of the nation's leading
cancer centers are joining forces today
to build on the work of the cancer
moonshot
i was able to do during the obama biden
administration to help break through
silos and barriers
in cancer research we're making progress
there's so
much we can do so much progress
within our reach and that's why i'm
thankful
the folks here today for getting their
vaccine shots
gerald bond who uh uh who and corey
hamilton uh both dc firefighters
i said to corey that you know that old
expression
god made man then he made a few
firefighters thank god we have them
and linda linda bussey is a manager of
safeway grocery store in bethesda
victoria uh legerwood rivera who is a
local school counselor
and elizabeth callaway who's a
registered nurse who administers these
shots
and the more people get vaccinated the
faster we're going to beat this pandemic
that's why one of my first goals in
office
when i was just before i sworn in i
indicated that
my goal was to get a hundred million
cobot vaccine shots
in people's arms in my first hundred
days as president
at first critics said that gold was too
ambitious no one could do that
then they said it was too small that the
bottom line though is that america
will be the first country perhaps the
only one to get that done
and today i'm here to report we're
halfway there
15 million shots in just 37 days since
i've become president
that's weeks ahead of schedule even with
the
setbacks we faced during the recent
winter storms
which devastated millions of midwestern
midwestern cities towns
and also the same in the south we're
moving in the right direction though
despite the mess we inherited from the
previous administration
which left us with no real plan to
vaccinate all americans
and every time we administer another 50
million shots
i'm going to use that milestone to
report to the american people on our
vaccination program and on our overall
fight against this pandemic
the good and the bad i'll tell you the
success and the failures
and here's the deal here's the deal the
story of this vaccination campaign is
like the story of everything hard
and new america does some confusion is
setbacks to the start and then if we do
the right things we have the right plan
to get things moving
that's what we're seeing right now weeks
before i became president the previous
administration saw
six million shots administering last
week this coming week we will administer
over 12 million
shots double the pace in just six weeks
that we've been in office
other milestones we've increased
vaccination distribution to states by
70 percent nearly 60 percent
of people over the age of 75 have now
received at least
one shot it was 14 6 weeks ago
and close to 50 percent of people over
the age of 65 have at least
one shot now it was eight percent six
weeks ago
it's important because people over 65
account for
eighty percent of all the cova desk
additionally
about 75 of the people who live in
long-term facilities
have gotten their first shot and those
cases are at the lowest level since
reporting began in may
here's how we've been doing it it starts
with increasing the supply
my team has worked very hard with
vaccine manufacturers
pfizer and moderna to ensure we have
enough supply
for all adult americans by the end of
july
when we had discovered the vaccine
manufacturers weren't being prioritized
when it came to securing supplies they
needed
to make the vaccine we fixed the problem
i used the defense production act to
speed up the supply
chain for key equipment which has
already helped increase vaccine
production
last week i toured the pfizer facility
manufacturing facility
in a plant in kalamazoo michigan
it's an incredible the precision
the safety the pride and the sense of
purpose everyone involved in that
process
and project has we've all seen the news
about johnson and johnson's vaccine
the idea of a third safe and effective
vaccine is very promising
the food and drug administration the fda
is reviewing the data
and review recommendations from outside
committee of experts
that will be meeting tomorrow now let me
be
clear we are going to do this the right
way
the fda will decide on emergency use
authorization
of a vaccine based on science not due to
any political pressure from me or anyone
else
no outside factors what i will say
to the american people is this if if
the fda approves the use of this new
vaccine
we have a plan to roll it out as quickly
as johnson johnson can make it we'll use
every conceivable way to expand
manufacturing of the vaccine
and we'll make even more rapid progress
on overall vaccines in march
i'll have more to say about this in the
days after the fda review
look we've been laser focused
on the greatest operational challenge
this country has ever undertaken
administering shots in the arms of
hundreds of millions of americans
we're increasing the number of
vaccinators
one we found was you may have the
vaccine but not enough people to put the
vaccinated vaccine in someone's arm like
you just saw
we brought back retired doctors and
nurses we've already deployed more than
1
500 medical personnel you see during
national disasters
from the federal emergency the federal
emergency management agency fema
and we commissioned our commission corps
from the department of health and human
services in the defense department
including the national guard
supplying vaccinators we're lining up
thousands
more to do the vaccinations we're also
setting up more places for people to get
vaccinated
as of today we provided 3.8 billion
dollars to states territories and
tribes to create hundreds of new
vaccination centers
and ramp up the existing ones are there
already
working with governors across the
country in red and blue states
to bolster their efforts to stand up
hundreds of vaccination centers
from stadiums to community centers
houses of worship
large parking lots we're providing
personnel and equipment
and covering the cost for the states
including for the use of their national
guard which have been they're incredible
today jill and i i should say tomorrow
jill and i will travel
to houston texas to tour one of the
first federal
mass vaccination centers and to thank
everyone involved this is an example of
the kind of partnership
between federal state local governments
and public and private partners that's
going to get this job
done we also sent millions of
vaccines to thousands of local
pharmacies all across america
to make it easier folks to get the
vaccine shot
like they would their flu shot going to
familiar place
familiar folks that they can trust and
know
to get the shot and for folks who didn't
live near
don't live near a vaccination center or
a pharmacy
we're deploying mobile units these are
special vehicles and pop-up clinics that
meet folks where they live
and where they don't have transportation
to get the shots
to get to the places to get the shots
we've also started to send vaccines
directly to community health centers
to help the hard the hard to reach folks
in cities and small towns and rural
communities in black latino native
american communities
that have higher rates of covent
infections and deaths
than any other groups as a result of
these round-the-clock efforts
in five weeks america's administered the
most shots of
any country in the world any country in
the world
with among the highest percentage of
population fully vaccinated
that's progress we promised it's also
true that while covert 19 vaccinations
are up
covert cases and hospitalizations are
coming down
but i need to be honest with you cases
and hospitalizations
could go back up with new variants as
they emerge
so i want to make something really very
clear this is not a time to relax
we must keep washing our hands stay
socially distanced
and for god's sake for god's sake wear
a mask some of our progress in this
fight is
because so many americans are stepping
up and doing those things
the worst thing we could do now is let
our guard down
of course it's my hope to come back in
the next
next uh to report that we've after we've
done another 50 million
another 50 million shots before the end
of my first 100 days
but here's the critical point as hard as
it is now to believe
we're going to hit a phase in this
effort
maybe as late as april or may
where many predict that instead of long
lines of people waiting to get a shot
we'll face a very different scenario
we'll have the vaccine
waiting we'll have ramped
up vaccine supplies we'll have
administrative
folks to administer the shots to the
most of the people
who aren't eager to get the shots
at least that's been the prediction i
don't think i think i don't think it's
going to happen i think more people see
other people getting the shots it's
going to build confidence
but you know at the same time they're
people who live in hard to reach areas
who can't get them and there are folks
who are hesitant to take the shot in the
first place
we all know there's a history in this
country of of
subjecting certain communities to
terrible medical and scientific abuse
but if there is one message that needs
to cut through it's this
the vaccines are safe and effective and
i believe as you see your neighbor your
husband your wife your son your daughter
getting it that you will be
much more inclined to get it listen to
dr fauci
listened to the scientists who developed
these vaccines
and the extensive and rigorous review
that went through
i did i took my shots publicly to
demonstrate to the american people
that it's safe and effective but the
time is coming
maybe 60 to 90 days when the supply
is adequate but not enough people can
access the shots
or don't want them to address that
challenge
we're going to launch a massive campaign
to educate people about vaccines
that they are safe and effective and
where to go to get those shots in the
first place
and we're going to bring together
leaders of all segments of our society
to educate and encourage
all americans to get vaccinated so i
hope the senate
will soon confirm a key leader of that
effort
my nominee for the secretary of health
and human service
javier bersera who did so well in this
hearing this
week i hope congress passes the american
rescue plan which i've been pushing
which which provides funds for
everything we need to do to beat this
pandemic and get the economy going again
now critics say the plan is too big that
it costs too much
but let me ask a rhetorical question
what would you have me
cut what would you have me cut out
on vaccines alone if we don't invest
20 million billion dollars to vaccinate
the nation doesn't that make sense
or 160 billion in total towards the
pandemic for
testing to protective gear to vaccine
production and distribution
i'm ready to hear any ideas on what will
make the american rescue plan better
stronger and effective
but we'll have to answer who will get
helped
and who will get hurt i want to close
with this
the question i ask i'm asked most often
is when will things get back to normal
my answer is always honest and
straightforward i can't give you a date
i can only promise that we'll work as
hard as we can
to make that day come as soon as
possible
while things are improving and we're
going from a mess we inherited to moving
in the right direction
at a significant speed this is not a
victory lap
this everything is not fixed we have a
long way to go
and the and that day when everything
gets back to normal
depends on all of us depends on congress
passing
the american recovery act research plan
recovery plan
and also for us to remain vigilant
to look out for one another i've said it
before
wash your hands stay socially distanced
wear a mask get the vaccine when it's
your turn
when your friend or neighbor or loved
one is eligible
encourage them to get vaccinated and
when all
above all remember we can do this
this is the united states america
there's nothing we can't do when we do
it together
so it's not over yet but we're getting
close
and god willing if we do all we know we
have to do
we're going to beat this beat it sooner
than later
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you for your time mr president mr
president whatever happened to your
promise from
seven weeks ago that if democrats
flipped the senate the checks were going
out the door
come on peter thank you guys thank you
this is the head-on